so you're thinking about coming back to
gta online next gen no wait you're
thinking about jumping into gta online
for the first time either way now is a
great time with a more streamlined
experience and lots of handholding for
new players rockstar has made gta online
approachable to anyone
for the first time in a long time gta
online servers are a mixed bag of
experienced players new players and
everyone in between personally i dusted
off my old account from 2014 when dr
dre's the contract dlc dropped
[ __ ] ass
after seven years i was a little
overwhelmed
gta online used to be constant drive-by
attacks remote explosions
bugattis and every millionaire living
right
here
now you can own businesses like clubs
and banks there are dozens of new
vehicles and dlc missions and of course
after all these years the character
customization is mind-boggling if that
seemed a little overwhelming starting
fresh with next gen might just be the
way to go for you let's break down what
starting over looks like
before you create your all new character
you're given loads of fun player options
right out of the gate along with 4
million gta bucks to start
first come selecting a criminal career
you're able to choose your path
cyberpunk style with your options being
executive gun runner nightclub owner or
biker next comes the bunker it's a
little weird but owning a bunker is
required to start it's a safe space for
you your arsenal and your cars there are
a few location options sprinkled around
northern san andreas and they range from
2.2 million dollars to free with this
very last option either way you need to
pick one and choose from a list of
optional upgrades and amenities if
you're getting one of the larger decked
out bunkers i'd suggest getting one of
these stupid little caddies if money
isn't an issue money isn't an issue you
can really take advantage of the space
with all the options they offer yet your
running around speed indoors is pretty
slow
once your bunker is designed how you
like it's time to pick from a selection
of cars and weapons i would advise you
to take your time here as much as i
wanted whatever the [ __ ] this is i
thought about the practicality of
something a little smaller this hvy
night shark has armor options and
surprisingly fast acceleration it's
perfect for getting out of a heist
personally i've seen this thing do
really well in online missions which
we'll discuss a little later anyway you
know what don't don't listen to me pick
what you want and live your life there's
a really nice selection of cars here
same with weapons there are a lot of
solid options here my only suggestion
would be getting something well-rounded
like an assault rifle because you can
always buy more later
money isn't an issue now it's time to
create your fresh-faced character who
has yet to be jaded by life in los
santos i went with the random option
myself and i have zero regrets my dude
looks like a rejected gta 3 character
with a suit and bandana
oh he blinked that's funny
now that you have your very own base and
vehicle and have selected a career path
it's time to leave the bunker and get
your life going your phone will be
blowing up with opportunities pay
attention to these early calls and texts
because you'll get several mission
offers to get you going as well as
information about how to claim great
freebies like a free car from your tuner
buddy howe and even free property
see you ain't even ready for this
also at this point i noticed the game
was running in fidelity mode which
displays at 30 frames per second this
mode isn't bad but if you want those
higher frames i'd suggest performance
mode or performance ray tracing mode to
know more about these three modes check
out our everything to know video in the
description
as far as setting up goes the biggest
stuff is now behind us and now you can
just sit back and start playing some gta
or if you're returning after a long time
it's time to begin your nostalgia trip
once you've made it into town you can
pick up your new cars and check out your
heist apartment that your buddy lester
set up for you from here on out you'll
continue getting mission invites from
familiar faces like martin madrazo
trevor phillips gerald and more if you
accept these early missions you'll find
the perfect blend of fun and nostalgia
without being too tough if you're new or
don't remember these were the same
opening missions offered back in 2013
with the launch of gta online in my
experience these were great to help me
get started all over again in next gen
or if you're a long time active player
these classic missions might be nice to
see in the rotation again and a fun
benefit of starting over all of these
missions are based on your rank as you
level up in your gta online career
you'll be offered more thorough missions
including heists which can earn you
millions
another benefit i've come across is that
like me a lot of people have chosen to
start fresh
mission lobbies are filled with lower
ranked players and we're all just sort
of reliving the early days of gta online
sometimes we screwed up but usually the
whole group would just hit reset and
we'd just try it again or this other
mission where a higher ranked player
just sort of helped me out he wasn't
pushy and he let me drive and do most of
the killing and he was really just there
for support it was pretty great and
after the mission ended he didn't try to
kill me or anything he just took off and
we parted ways
it's kind of weird to say but even with
the game as violent as gta online the
vibes were just good
it reminded me of 2013 all over again
which was a big reason why i wanted to
make this video gta online next gen is a
fun place to be right now and i'm
hopeful that this feeling will last for
a while since the next gen console
market is such a joke but while people
are still waiting to bag a ps5 or a new
xbox more and more players will start
gta fresh just like us for years to come
okay here are some last minute tips for
anyone who is brand new to gta online
first remember to use your interaction
menu by pressing and holding the
touchpad on the ps5 or the view button
on xbox this sub menu's got a lot of
great shortcuts like enabling passive
mode which prevents people from killing
you if you need a moment it's also a
great way to eat some snacks and regain
health equip armor you've purchased and
even customize your character's moves
which you can do to anyone at any time
next is your phone your player's cell
phone is the hub of opportunity it's
where you go to find property listings
it's how you purchase a car and it's the
easiest way to deposit your money after
you complete a mission and get paid out
it doesn't directly go into your bank
account but rather your wallet which
people can pick off of your wasted body
so use the deposit feature and just use
your cell phone it's also the way to
interact with every npc you come across
your friends like lamar and lester all
have your back in one way or another hey
call me back when you found yourself a
brain
as you level up you'll get more
abilities like being able to put a
bounty on someone having a car delivered
to you wherever you need it and way more
if you're a veteran gta online player
feel free to leave more tips and tricks
of your own down in the comments
we hope you found this video helpful
show some love and drop a like if you
did and remember to subscribe to
gamespot for more videos just like this
thanks for watching
[Music]
you